[Musique]
bonjour alors bonjour à deux invités ont
maintenant à savoir noëlle bréham et à
la marathon bonjour voila nous ferons la
gentillesse de se retrouver sur le
plateau de télé fils vous avez plein
plein de points communs tous les deux
vous êtes d'abord yvelinois la voie des
voisins voilà vous avez un travail dans
la même maison à savoir france inter
puisque noël
vous avez donc deux émissions france
inter alain une émission chronique une
chronique mali dans deux semaines et je
n'ai pas de noël non non on est un jour
déjà un avantage néanmoins sais que je
possède les clefs du jardin ou noël
adorent venir se ressourcer il dit un
truc vachement sa part paris va tacler
derrière et puis ils n'ont même pas ab
non non non non non avec le des
compléments parce que l'idée de d'animer
une émission qui s'appelle ne serait ce
que vraiment les petits bateaux ton
c'est extraordinaire et côté une écoute
cette émission moi j'ai un souvenir
extraordinaire
un enfant qui posait une question un
scientifique mais de très haut niveau et
est ce que les marguerites avait
toujours le même nombre de pétales et ce
gamin laquelle ont été grandioses et
cette femme qui était je crois une
scientifique répondait d'une manière
mais absolument un voilà c'est
exactement
gd l'émission j'étais dans un
embouteillage je rentrais de week-end et
pleuvait des trombes d'eau le soleil
brillait dans ma voiture
on écoute et écoutez moi le soleil mais
elle est un petit peu sage non si vous
allez me dire ce que vous voyez à
l'écran qu'est ce que cette excellente a
fini tu l'as dit que c'était le nombre
d'or à la barre garcia bah non il a pas
dit que c'était le nombre d'or la
marguerite le nombre de pétales et
marguerite neuf à la tête du top s'est
exprimé je ne voulais pas laisser les
gens n'aient pas trop empiéter sur le
travail de l'américain veut voilà mais
c'est vrai que c'est le nom mais c'est
vrai que c'était expliqué mais c'est un
intérêt de des émissions de noël merci
justement c'est bien simple elle vous a
parlé à la hanche est vrai que je repars
laisser je vous faire parler d'autre
chose parce que l'émission est courte
mais belle et du coup alors qu'est ce
qu'on voit à l'écran on voit un endroit
où vous aimez vous promenez j'imagine ce
que c'est votre endroit préféré dans le
parc
j'ai envie de nom c'est beau c'est beau
mais c'est pas votre came c'est un
jardin pense qu elle va être d'accord
avec moi nous sommes dans les jardins de
l'orangerie c'est beau mais les plantes
sont captés elles vivent en caisse c'est
un jardin de pouvoir ce n'est pas un
jardin de plaisir c'est un jean n'a
d'autorité
c'était pas un lieu où l'on prendra
plaisir à s'isoler à rêver voire même à
pleurer c'est beau à regarder
d'accord il n'y a pas d'âme il ya pas d
c'est bien là mais c'est quand même
c'est quand même joli ici oui voilà donc
est ce que vous êtes au courant que bien
en ce moment et pour que de moi je crois
qu'à 24 juillet jusqu'au 24 juillet
pardon a lieu une très belle exposition
au grand palais qui s'appelle jardin et
dont voici la fiche à l'écran vous
pouvez nous en parler un tout petit peu
dit très heureux très heureux que 2010
soit l'année du jardin l'exposition
jardins grand palais jardin infinie au
centre pompidou metz à giverny à une
grande manifestation toutes les villes
de france organise des célébrations
autour du jardin je suis très heureux et
celle du grand palais pour répondre à
votre question est magnifique elle est
magnifique parce que le jardin et le
jardin sont mises en valeur dans le
dossier de presse eh bien il ya une
la reproduction d'un tableau je crois
des 1000 clause qui est un pâtre belge
on voit un vieux jardinier qui est
debout qui tient dans ses mains un pot
de bégonias et qui va rentrer dans une
maison bourgeoise
après avoir pris soin de retirer ses
savons le tableau est très émouvant
c'est ça cette exposition c'est de
l'émotion on y retrouve des textes de
gilles clément on y voit des tableaux
suivis par les grands noms de la
peinture bien sûr mais aussi des
anonymes
on peut s'y égarer on a trouvé des noms
comme le bosquet pour pouvoir contempler
quelques vieux documents historiques
très belle très très belle manifestation
très belle exposition
il faut jamais dire quoi on a longtemps
pour aller voir une exposition il sait
quand on rate un avion parfois on est
arrivés en avance on fait les boutiques
et puis pouf et on s'en va
voilà donc allons-y demain voilà
allons-y demain oc soir une image
bientôt qui va où là là mais qu'est ce
alain bas je le dirai je suis peut-être
même près de dates et le l'automne
nathan oui quand un arbre en automne
d'accord il ya là une forme un peu
particulière
j'ai beaucoup régulière je trouve peu
parlé avant la prochaine photo envoyée à
l'essai moi j'ai beaucoup aimé ce qu'a
dit alain sur france inter pour ne pas
citer la radio il ya quelques temps à
propos des feuilles des arbres de vie du
canton taille un arbre donc forcément on
coupe la branche on coupe les feuilles
qui avec et les feuilles des arbres vous
avez dit alain baraton je vous vois pas
ce que c'est sérieux
vous avez dit ce sont des capteurs
solaires donc on le on le prive en le
privant de ses feuilles le stream de
l'énergie par seulement la plante
produit des feuilles qui vont nous
servir principalement pour deux raisons
la première c'est le capteur solaire
c'est la lumière du soleil qui va
permettre à la plante de transformer
l'eau et des sels minéraux qu'elle a
absorbée dans la terre en énergie en
nourriture assimilable par les tissus de
la plante
mais pour que la sève monte dans l'âme
on n'y pense jamais mais comme on l'a 16
fait-elle pour grimper enlèvement
y at il un moteur kubota l'eifel
dans chaque fun il ya des sports et
chaque sport alger comme validé petit
clapet que l'on ne voit pas bien sûr
comme des mini pompe
c'est pour ça que en automne lorsque
l'hiver menace la plante se sépare de
ses feuilles plus de feuilles plus de
pompage on est en dormance donc quand on
coupe les des branches quand on supprime
des feuilles on prive le végétal de la
pompe hydraulique et des poumons
comment voulez-vous que l'argent serait
alors que fait-elle elle se dépêche
d'ems reproduire et bien pour pouvoir
surmonter le déficit est elle en souffre
juste un chiffre un tilleul non taillés
à une espérance de vie de huit cents ans
c'est l'état y est régulièrement 150 ans
de la toutes ses formes et en plus on
empêche les petits trésors de falorni
voilà on n'empêche qu'on tout autre
chose
est-ce que je peux mais malaisie je fais
très attention avec baraton à c'est
comme la queue du lézard g10 du lézard
c'est à dire qu'on peut s'amuser quand
on avait regardé la salle non parce que
effectivement il en a l'âge pour papa
mais repousse mais c'est comme le
pillage au prix d'une énergie
refabriquer vocera la mefou énorme et
donc comme métier lévis - les plus
fragiles vont marquer que je alimentaire
je ne mens pas répondu au sourire alors
j'aurais pu rappeler cette petite
martigné de coluche a qui ont recommandé
de cuire toujours les cerises avec
l'accusé on lâche déjà du mal avec les
mains voilà ça c'est fait
[Rires]
voilà bon un peu de sagesse encore une
fois qu'est-ce que donc la nature ça
vous réunit les lieux dans versailles
qui vous on chante plus dans le parc est
ce que vous avez des points communs
c'était voilà moi je partage quand même
un peu avec alain quand il a dit que
tout à l'heure que l'orangerie ça ça
avait de la gueule mais les coins les
plus charmants sont pas seuls a
effectivement c'est l'écho un peu plus
enfouies à l'emmener nous quelque part
ce sont les endroits où les hommes clés
du 10 volumes
ce sont les arbres qui n'ont pas
vraiment été travaillée on y sent là
bien sûr on y veille et puis il faut
versailles c'est un lieu qu'il faut
découvrir sans aucun guide surtout par
un téléphone portable on y va à
l'instinct de temps en temps on marche
on voit des ceux qui viennent en ce
moment dans le parc regarde au loin ils
voient des couleurs il s'approche et
tombe sur des magnolias ont fui ces
sublimes
ils ne sont pas inscrits sur les poèmes
yahia qui est voté il ya pas très
longtemps car ils ont une petite
centaine d'années camélia avec les
médias qui ont été plantés au petit
trianon qui colorent les partenaires va
confondre magnolia l'or car il ya donc
ça c'est l'union de vote lire le manuel
et icloud qui était ainsi baptisé pour
rendre hommage à pierre magnol alors que
camélia rend hommage à joseph kamel et
lin et ben oui oui non mais et on a mis
les halles
après leur non ça ne nous a pas lieu à
bégoux bégonias kamel camélia dalle
dalle ya tout ici est moins cher alain
vous trouvez une fleur ça sera la barre
à tania aurez beaucoup de mais alors
juste pour entre le camélia et le
manadier il ya aucun point commun cette
fois la même famille c'est pas la même
fleurs vous avez dit un jour à une
émission sur cette télévision là sur
cette même antenne que à propos la du
camellia que le thé c'était de la le thé
de chine
je me suis demandé est une contrepétrie
l'hôtel chine c'était du camellia j'ai
cherché j'ai maintenant
ne tentez pas et je le temps de raconter
une petite histoire mais l'anglais
achète depuis toujours aux anglais il ya
longtemps au chinois avic tout à fait
donc les anglais achète aux chinois le
thé est au bout d'un moment ils se
disent mais pourquoi acheter du thé
achetons plus tôt le tennis l'appli
produit justement de quoi faire du thé
mais les anglais ne sont pas ne sont pas
les chinois ne sont pas vous s'ils
vendent les arbres ils ne vendront plus
de thé et leur vendent non pas des
camélias de chine
mais les camélias du japon et les
anglais n'y voit que du feu ils
reviennent en angleterre avec camilla du
japon constatent trop tard qu'ils ne
pourront pas faire de pc sans faire mais
ils découvrent une plante à la floraison
incroyable quelques dizaines quelques
petites centaines d'années ensuite et
bien alexandre dumas à son tour tombe
admiratrice du camellia du japon il a
écrit et bien un ouvrage houle son
héroïne souffre de problèmes pulmonaires
alors le camélia ne sont ne dégage pas
de doder donc il va l'intitulé la dame
aux camélias un hommage donc à marie
duplessis
ensuite ma verdi avec la la traviata et
pour la petite anecdote quand caen dumas
écrit sa dame aux camélias
ils se trompent dans l'orthographe au
lieu de mettre deux ailes comme il
aurait dû le faire
il est nommé 15 heures calmes et or le
livre est un succès un succès planétaire
et du coup on retient les deux écritures
camélia peut aujourd'hui s'écrire avec
un ou deux elles pas mal de riders avec
une question de la radio et écrire des
livres vous noël continue à nous
enchanter avec moi tous vos invités que
vous avez déniché une saison comme tant
de pépites qui nous font du soleil sur
le corps mais oui voila merci à tous les
deux c'est gratuit
et ben oui on va lire ce livre donc
comme on avait dit et l'offrir et
l'offrir on leur offrir on le recommande
la fête des mères
on le voit comme un on nous donne
délicatement comme un bouquet de muller
je remercie parce que j'aime le jardin
jusqu'au 24 juillet n'en baraton il a du
mal à donner mais bon allez salut merci
à bientôt
[Musique]